this morning we're going to continue our
kindness 101 series with Steve Hartman
sharing stories built around kindness
and character I love that intro uh and
people who've mastered those qualities
we could all use a tip now and again
today's lesson is in honesty Steve and
his kids show us that it's usually the
best policy of course even if you're not
so sure you're gonna like the way the
cookie crumbles when you fess up
good morning this is my daughter Meryl
and today I'm going to be perfectly
Frank with you because today's class is
about honesty and for a definition let's
toss it over to my brother Emma at the
dictionary desk Emmett good morning
Merle honesty is basically not telling
lies and not being deceptive in any way
perfect have you ever lied about
anything
um yes but not on a basis not on a wet
basis not on a regular basis I think
everyone has lied there's even studies
showing that parents lie
I've never seen such a study
like what would a parent possibly lie
about I totally didn't eat the Oreos you
got me there there was like a whole row
of God I don't like the direction this
is going I feel like everyone has to lie
at some point why do you think people
aren't honest all the time I feel like
oftentimes people have a fear of being
in trouble yeah dishonesty can get you
short-term gains but if you're honest
the long-term gains can be so much more
rewarding
to prove the point let's look at a
classic from our archives a story that
shows just how rewarding honesty can be
[Music]
of all the things a little girl can
aspire to Charlotte McCourt of South
Orange New Jersey says the most
important of these is to be truthful yes
it's like a core feeling why so
important to you
because if you're not honest then what
are you
Charlotte says the first eight words of
the Girl Scout Law are I will do my best
to be honest
so when it came time to paddle her Girl
Scout cookies she decided to tell her
customers the whole truth in this letter
to one customer that went viral on the
internet she wrote the Girl Scout
organization can sometimes use false
advertisement she then graded the
cookies she gave the dosey doe a five
for its unoriginal Bland flavor while
saving most of her venom for the dreaded
toffee tastic she gave it a one for
being a bleak flavorless gluten-free
Wasteland it's as flavorless as dirt she
wrote my sister and I threw out the box
like we tried everything we tried
dunking it in tea we tried dunking and
hot chocolate is just gross would you
like to buy some Girl Scout cookies as
you might expect brutal honesty like
that can have a dramatic impact on sales
Charlotte was hoping to sell 300 boxes
is that all but she got nowhere near
that nowhere near that's you that is all
me when we visited she had our already
sold more than 23
000 boxes how do you explain this truth
and advertising apparently honesty has
become such an aberration the truth so
sadly missed that when all these people
read Charlotte's letter they felt
compelled to support her I sold
thousands of Samos and thousands of thin
mints have you sold any toffee tactics
to my grandmother
it was before Charlotte wrote the letter
just what box
so then she gave him her to her friend
who has a dog no who has gluten allergy
okay
so there is your hope America that
Honesty can and will prevail
hard to imagine a better role model for
honesty than Charlotte McCourt who joins
us now hello Charlotte hello
where did you learn to be so honest
from my parents my parents were very
honest to me growing up and that kind of
taught me how to live my life and how to
live my life honestly do you think
honesty is always the best policy or are
there exceptions like when my wife asked
me if she looks good in a dress
honesty doesn't have to be your raw
opinion you can present honesty in a
kind way and honesty and kindness don't
have to conflict so I think instead of
being honest all the time just live your
life with an air of honesty so what do
you want to be when you grow up
I really want to work in politics I
would love to be like a chief of staff
for a senator so you're giving up on the
honesty thing
you can do both you can do both you know
that's not a field known for its honesty
I think that's why it's so important to
bring honesty into it well I think
you've got our vote right thanks for
being with us thank you
so that wraps up another successful
class and to celebrate I'd like to
reward you both with a heaping helping
of toffee tastics really really
they're horrible no does anybody have
water we'll see you next time and don't
forget to stay kind
well surely did say that they're quite
dry she was telling the truth I think
she'd be great in politics yeah she
needs to bring some of that Honesty
because Steve that's right a lot of
politicians are very fluid with the
truth they could use people actually
yeah I hope she can change Washington
and Washington doesn't change her
that was good yeah nicely done well done